turning now to the winter olympics in
beijing where the once obscure sport of
curling continues can you believe it
gain popularity that's i believe it yeah
it's like a knockout it's a cult
only now do i like it well that's partly
due to team usa which took a surprise
goal four years ago in south korea jamie
yuka spent time with the team and
captain john schuster at their training
camp and she joins us again from beijing
i know you love it
i love curling michelle i don't know
what you guys are talking about it is
though a little deja vu all over again
john schuster's team barely made it to
the metal round before catching fire in
pyeongchang and here in the beijing
bubble team shuster is on the bubble not
yet qualified for the medal round that's
just the way it goes for the so-called
team rejects
launching a 40-pound rock a hundred feet
down a slippery icy surface toward a
six-foot target demands intense levels
of skill dedication and mental fortitude
described as chess on ice curling slow
pace and team drama make for great tv
moments and let me tell you it's as hard
as it looks
[Laughter]
and in a team made up of players
sporting long hair tattoos and one
iconic mustache
nicknamed the rejects and you have one
heck of a cinderella story after a run
of disastrous results shuster's team was
cut from usa curling's elite program but
instead of folding he came back with a
team of outsiders by 2014 you're getting
kicked out of the high performance
program
you start your own club
name the rejects how did you come up
with the region we did not come up with
rejects somebody else named us
they did yeah because we were we were
the people that they didn't want anymore
and i was head reject in 2010 his first
games as the u.s olympic men's team skip
that's captain to you and me shuster's
run ended with a last place finish four
years later another let down in sochi
where they placed ninth out of 10 teams
after the humiliation schuster and
teammate john landsteiner realized they
were on their own how did that feel i
knew we were going to have to do
something on our own
and i was going to have to hopefully
find three or four other players that
also didn't make the program that had
some sort of talent and we could figure
it out and i mean lucked out obviously
they rebuilt earning back their olympic
birth and setting the stage for their
historic run in pyeongchang
a come-from-behind run to the gold medal
game ended with them becoming the first
americans to bring home olympic curling
gold a feet dubbed the mirror curl on
ice it didn't matter whether or not i
had
you know the support of usa curling or
not because that's the beauty of our
sport is no one can stop you from just
winning your way there shuster and
teammates john landsteiner matt hamilton
and newcomer chris plies say that the
team's unity through the roller coaster
years has made them stronger that's do
you think part of the attraction to your
team specifically is because you've got
a lot of personalities we're all very
different but it's just
funny how like people from
that are so different uh personalities
can gel so well and make like one really
cohesive unit so it's fun to be a part
of
this will be the first olympics for
chris prize as an official part of team
shuster despite being the newbie he says
the team has a togetherness and a
relaxed fit that suits him the guys are
cool i think the cool part about our
team is like everybody's just themselves
and there's no pressure like you want
space take your space you want to do
this like someone's usually down so
i enjoy it if any team is ready for the
mental challenge that comes with olympic
size pressure it's team shuster you know
a major
thing to get out of your own head when
you're you know throwing the rock or
getting your mind in the right place to
deliver the stone in a in an effective
way but then
you know there's also
what you need to be communicating with
each other and probably the most
important thing we ever did was find out
even why we all love playing the game i
love playing the game because i love the
strategy component of it
the team is gung-ho about their chances
and is relishing the competition how do
you hope the team performs i think this
is going to be the best olympics ever as
far as like the depth goes the
international
curling scene has just gotten so strong
which is awesome because
nobody wants to see canada winning all
the time well i mean except canadians
except for canadians yeah and then yeah
yeah we're not talking about canada
right now the rejects still have three
matches left against switzerland italy
and denmark to make it to the middle
round and then who knows perhaps
lightning will strike twice that's what
we're looking for tony
best olympics ever and yeah no who wants
canada to win come on
jamie yuka is another delightful story
from beijing jamie thank you very much